Remember, we're mostly funded by membership's
people who just go to join Pakman Dotcom and
sign up, it's quick, it's easy.
You get the daily bonus show just for our
paid members and it just feels good.
You can use the coupon code fresh, start to
get 70 percent off your choice of membership.
Pick anyone you like at join Pakman Dotcom.
There's simply no way to tell you how insane
this story is without screaming and going
crazy, but I'm going to try to do it while
while sort of remaining calm if it's possible.
Donald Trump, the president of the United
States, who lost the November election by
a lot to Joe Biden and is scheduled to leave
the White House in a month, had a meeting
at the White House this weekend where he discussed
with lawyers declaring martial law and forcibly
seizing voting machines.
See how calmly I said that the calmness with
which I set it has no connection whatsoever
to the complete and utter insanity and depravity
of the situation.
And considering martial law isn't the only
thing that Donald Trump did during this meeting,
Trump is considering naming that complete
nut lawyer, Sydney Powell.
She's the conspiracy theorist attorney who
Trump said just weeks ago, has nothing to
do with anything he's doing.
Trump is considering naming her special counsel
to oversee a supposed voter fraud investigation.
This is the same woman who said that there's
a Venezuelan plot also involving antifa George
Soros and a guy named Eric Coomber to steal
the election.
Trump is considering naming her special counsel.
Trump and Rudy Giuliani want the Department
of Homeland Security to seize voting machines,
to examine them and some of Donald Trump's
lawyers.
And if chief of staff, his chief of staff
said, you know, you actually can't do that.
Now, at one point in this meeting when people
were telling Trump the things you want to
do are against the law, Sydney Powell reportedly
started chastising them, saying that they
were quitter's.
They were unwilling to do what needed to be
done.
When Donald Trump was told, you know, Department
of Homeland Security, they can't just go and
seize voting machines legally from the states.
Trump suggested, what if I sign an executive
order to seize the voting machines, which
Trump's lawyer, Pat Spallone, said, yeah,
we also can't do that.
And then, yes, Donald Trump asked the team
about imposing martial law, as suggested previously
recently by Donald Trump's indicted and later
pardoned former national security adviser
Michael Flynn, who during a recent appearance
on Newsmax said Trump should declare martial
law.
So this is where we are right now.
This is now the insane situation in which
we find ourselves.
The president is actually thinking and saying
out loud to lawyers, what if I impose martial
law to avoid having to admit that I lost the
election in order to try to steal it?
And meanwhile, the Trump administration is
saying that it's bad that a Biden adviser
used a bad word last week.
Make it.
Can you.
Can you imagine?
Everything is backwards.
Trump wants to look at seizing voting machines.
People around Trump are telling him bad idea,
it's illegal.
And Trump considers naming the woman they
recently said had nothing to do with them
to oversee all of this.
And you know what's really insane?
When word of this and other harebrained plans
previously have leaked, a bunch of Trump's
followers react and they say, oh, you know,
this is this.
This is to say they don't instead of saying,
wow, that's too far that this even this I
voted for Trump, but even this is too much.
They react by saying, you know, if Trump is
thinking of doing this, it must be part of
some brilliant plan because Trump always has
something up his sleeve.
Trump, he must be playing for each other.
Remember Benghazi and the 11 congressional
hearings that were held to look at what crimes
Hillary committed, which turned out to be
none.
There have been no hearings over Trump's complete
mishandling of the pandemic in which more
than 300000 Americans have died.
And there is no discussion, at least right
now, about, wait a second, if we had 11 hearings
over Benghazi, shouldn't we be looking into
what the president is doing, talking about
martial law, seizing voting machines and a
special counsel to investigate nonexistent
voter fraud that doesn't deserve an investigation?
The last month that we have to go here at
this point, I guess it's 29, 30 days.
This last month is not going to be calm and
boring.
It's going to be off the rails.
Outrageous.
That's very clear.
And on the tail end of this, remember, as
Donald.
Trump is doing this, much of the populist
left is talking about how AOC might not meet
their progressive purity tests.
That's what the left spent their weekend on
as Trump is talking about martial law in the
Oval Office.
So earlier in the show, we already talked
about that will follow up on that.
And we will also keep an eye on what what
is happening in the Oval Office.
Trump doesn't go out publicly.
He's not been seen for, I don't even know,
weeks now.
But he's talking about this stuff in the Oval
Office.
We'll continue to follow it.